ein sehr abwechslungsreicher beruf und
besserung der anspruch vorne gerufen
habe trinkwasser zu tun das lebensmittel
nummer eins man hat mit energien zu tun
mit gas und öl mit pellets mit
wärmepumpe modernsten techniken man
sollte auf jeden fall spaß am handwerk
haben und auch spaß an groben arbeiten
aber auch spaß an filigranen arbeiten
weil dieses kommt alles zusammen und das
von minute eins an ein guter
anlagenmechaniker muss logisch denken
muss in mathematik ganz gut sein und
muss im prinzip auch spaß am handwerk
haben und auch mit seinen händen
arbeiten können die ausbildung dauert
dreieinhalb jahre und ist aufgeteilt in
schulisch und praktische arbeiten man
hat immer zwei oder einen tag in der
woche schule und den rest ist man mit
den kollegen unterwegs auf den
baustellen erstmal als anlagenmechaniker
geselle wenn man weiter ausbilden kann
ich mir selber kann man auf jeden fall
einen kundendienst arbeiten und kann auf
baustellen arbeiten man kann einen
neubau arbeiten
man kann sich natürlich auch
weiterentwickeln man kann nach seinem
bachelor machen dann kann seinen master
machen man kann seinen meister machen
kann seinen techniker machen
es gibt vielfältige
entwicklungsmöglichkeiten reihen unsere
los mehr gefallen am meisten die
badsanierung weil man da von minute eins
bei den groben arbeiten schon ganz genau
arbeiten muss sonst wird das endergebnis
nicht dementsprechend wie es gewünscht
ist und dass es halt dieses
faszinierende dass man trotz ziemlich
grobe arbeit und staub und lärm und
dreck schon extrem genau arbeiten muss
das fordert eine hohe konzentration